Oh, you just pointed at a contradiction. Oh, well, I'm going
to state my worldview from scratch. Okay, what are you going
to do? >> This is gish galloping, right? Where you just
load a whole bunch of and the point is like somewhere in nowhere
anything that you've said, but now I'm overwhelmed with information
that you just threw at me. >> Well, it's Come on, Connor.
Can't you control your wife's Twitter like you control her bank
account? >> I didn't know Connor<unk>'s wife. She
>> I don't care. >> Shut up. No one asked you. Shut
up.
>> Yeah. Gish galloping implies that you're making a point.
There is no point. This is just >> just he starts reconstructing
his worldview. He's like he like literally his brain blue screens
and he's like I'm going to redefine my entire world view for
you so that hopefully you forget whatever we were talking about.
Where is the Conor thing? Where is it?
>> I'm I'm staying. >> Okay.
Well,
where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? There it
is.
>> I do not think that DJT should be smoked for his alleged
crimes in reference to >> But alleged? No, let me let me
finish. You're saying alleged? What if someone was certain that
he did them? >> Oh, sorry. >> Also, this panel is
about political violence in general. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Are
you certain that he did them?
>> Oh, but you say it all the time. >> I'm putting
it I'm putting it Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I'm putting it at
a very high probability. And as a matter of fact, I almost guarant
>> Wait, this is Is Connor really showing up and going
actually I think there's a really high chance Trump is a so I'm
just going to call him a >> He has already called him a
>> I know he's saying I'm calling him cuz it's a very high
chance. Is Connor really the guy who should be making that argument?
I feel like he's got
>> Listen, I feel like I I
the FBI says the FBI says, not Epste, but the FBI says Epstein
had child. Okay. Connor's friend himself said that he has child.
So like for to me I'm like, okay, that that seems like a higher
chance. Some weird [__] going on there.
>> That if you turned off your tribal brain for 3 seconds,
if a Democrat had similar evidence in reference to them, you
would be as confident as I am. Like destiny. >> Yeah. Like
it's just a I'm sorry. It's like super >> No. Like uh
hold on hold. No. No. We need to not mean. We need to not mean.
We need to be serious. >> Oh, now it's ser Now it's very
serious, >> So, do you think that Steven's crimes, alleged
crimes are as serious as the alleged crimes of Donald Trump?
>> It depends on what you're alleging. I haven't heard
anyone alleged that he had inappropriate fornication with children
other than you.
>> Even the alleged victims say I've alleged that. So,
hold on. said he is a key. Blank blank blank. You said it over
and over again. >> No, no, no. I said that other people.
I
>> No, you said it earlier. >> You said
misfits making his exit. Do you have any final words, misfit?
>> No. Listen, this was great. Uh, thank you for the conversation
and
yeah, I'll see you later.
>> Multiple times in arguments with Rob. >> All right.
You're really, real quick, just to clarify, you're really denying
that you never called Donald Trump a >> that word. >> Oh,
no, no, no. 100% I called Donald Trump that. I thought you just
said you didn't. You said
>> no. Use proper nouns and I'll understand what you're
saying. >> Everybody else understood what I was saying.
I said, >> okay, well, I didn't. So, sorry. >> I
thought your IQ was really
low. >> I'm capable of answering your question. >> wait,
why the [__] Okay, that's now the dumbest thing said
on this panel. What the [__] gave Rob that impression?
You don't need to spur out about it. Okay. >> So, okay.
So, hold on. Do you want to talk about Steven or do you want
to talk about Donald Trump? >> I want to talk about your
claims that Donald Trump that you believe that he is
>> Yeah, sure. Okay. So, let's talk about >> So,
the these are the facts that are not in dispute. Okay. Jeffrey
Epstein in the 80s, 90s, and early thousands recruited teenage
girls into a
uh trafficking operation.
Okay? And he had parties in two location, three locations that
we know of. One of them was a private jet known as the Lolita
Express. One of them was the island. The other one was a penthouse
in New York. Okay, those are the three places. All of this has
been confirmed by Jeffrey Epstein's own convictions.
The people who have associated with Jeffrey Epstein include Bill
Gates, Bill Clinton, Donald Trump, and Alan Dersowitz. Alan Dersowitz,
who is the lawyer who got Jeffrey Epstein. >> Call him
that right now. Duritz done yet. I'm not done yet. I'm painting
a picture. You can wait. Alan Dersowitz himself
wrote an op-ed in the 1990s arguing for reduction of the age
of consent to the age of 14. >> And Virginia Duffrey said
that underage she had multiple times relations with Alan Ders.
>> can you sing that? >> Super high. I can >> call
him that. Call him it. >> Okay. Call him it. >> What's
that? >> Call him it. Call him that word. Go ahead. Call
him it right now. Well, I don't want to because Sarah said that
it's a bad word. But I will say Alan Dersuitz is likely a >> No,
no, no. Don't say likely. Go X right now and write it. Go to
X right now and say Alan Dersitz is a blank. Go for it. >> Don't
say
just maybe he'll take Maybe he'll take >> I want I want
to point out Can I point out that Ryan? >> You really are
you really going over to X to do it?
>> So, as he gets I'll say this. I'll say this. As he says
this, I haven't heard any this >> Ah, man. And I should
>> Nothing he said there had anything to do with Donald
Trump had any >> Wait, what are you about to say? >> The
host kind of looks like a clown in a weird way that I'm like
uncomfortable like talking about. >> Oh, we disagree completely.
I think she's beautiful.
I like I like everything about how she looks. I understand now
people are like weird if you have an arch to your like eyebrows.
I think she looks good. >> That's like not it >> proof
whatsoever that Donald Trump did anything with underage children.
You're not going to be able to prove that case. It's just this
is all just >> I think I think I think
I can understand how she would have been attractive like as a
young I feel like there's like Botox or something going on that
Yeah. It's like >> No, I don't think it's bo It's It's
a lot of blush, but I don't mind it. I'm telling you, blue eyes
are actually disgusting and everyone who has blue eyes should
get contacts because most of the time blue eyes comes off as
really
>> I don't think that's it. I don't think that's it.
>> This is all just projection. This is all just projection.
The point that I made was I haven't even uh Bill Gates. Hold
on. Have you ever read Katie Johnson's >> No. The woman
that later recanted
>> Wait, is that the woman that later >> No, that
by the way, she didn't recant. She took a settlement from Alan
Dersuitz.
>> This skin thing. Also, she might like be a really nice
person. I have no idea. I've never heard her really talk on her
panel. She kind of just runs the panels. So, like I don't want
to uh
>> You guys say what you want. I think she's very >> I'm
not But Virginia never accused Trump of anything. That's not
who Effigy was talking about. >> Yeah, because she didn't
hook up with Donald Trump. Okay, that's why are you interjecting
on effig's point about a completely another woman to talk about
Virginia again?
>> Because it paints the picture that all of these people
were hanging out with 14 to 17year-old prostitutes and they knew
they were underage and they engaged in illegal activity. Rob,
>> have you seen any of the alleged victims say that Donald
Trump did anything with
>> Uh I I can find it. >> Oh my god. Johnson. >> Well,
he's finding it. Uh, Lord of the Nerd says Trump plan kicked
uh greater than Pence. Uh, greater than kick to the house, greater
than kick to the house. Or maybe this is like >> these
are just directions. Never mind. >> Can I share in the
chat? >> Yeah. Yeah. Uh, all three Democratic branches
need agree all legal before the reform act. You lose, dorks.
What was the legal theory for the traitor Dems kneeling to the
Antifa/BLM
losers? Uh can I can I speak this a little bit? I mean what like
I think the part of the whole electoral uh the act that passed
like would have it it didn't really it wouldn't have affected
this specific situation cuz Pence didn't actually follow through
by doing what Trump wanted him to do, right? Pence didn't actually
accept that. So I think the electoral reform act is supposed
to stop uh Pence from being able to do what Trump wanted him
to do. Uh but it so um I think that was the >> that was
a big issue, right? It was already explained to this guy why
there >> like a minute or so she removes >> angry
swear bear of the left lost deal with it. A misfit one spell
it out with
>> Also I I do have a question for the panel. Um if just
real it's kind of relevant with uh toos violations are extra
legal around these parts and Harry Lugwig uh sending love just
because and Rob should tell the panel his Rob should tell the
panel his cup and band size and then take a 10-minute break.
Oh, that's a boot. Does anybody want to negate the boot? I'll
give it a minute. >> I will do. >> Can I Somebody
>> There's a ton of pays. Yeah, I've watched this. I've
watched this panel get just insane amounts of money before. She'll
pay people to um she'll pay to get people kicked off. She'll
or she'll let you pay to kick somebody off. She'll let you pay
to do the oneonone thing. So, it's probably what happened is
I'm guessing he probably actually got like 50 bucks or 100 bucks
to do a one-on-one between Rob and Connor.
that's the cup thing that they were just talking about. >> It's
like bra size, cup size, band size.
>> yeah. Calling Rob fat. >> Okay. While they're
figier
>> I don't know if I can do both.
>> About the topic, the original like topic of the debate.
>> I was under the impression that this was like with the
in the context of Charlie Kirk in the last in last week's
>> Why would it be? >> So So extra. What do you mean
why would it be?
>> That's a very specific That's a very specific thing.
>> [__] Like why would
supposed to be assassinated and then now we're talking about
is >> so Minnesota lawmakers were assassinated like a couple
months ago as well.
>> So if we had the same if we had the same panel two months
ago whenever they were assassinated you would probably assume
the same thing right that it was about >> Yes. So you have
to assume that we're talking about it in the in that context.
>> I I didn't
ask a question. >> Go ahead. Is that the context of of
the
>> saying she's from the Alex the PWF community? I thought
so. I've seen Andrew come on her panels and like support her
panels a lot. Like that's who I've seen who comes on and she
gets like huge donations when Andrew comes on for Andrew to like
oneonone people.
>> Yeah. This radical coder guy comes on her panels too.
>> Watch Andrew American Nacho >> offer that guy
some money. Kind of crazy.
Yeah. American Nacho. Recognize him too. Um,
I feel like Queen knew about this this woman. >> Yeah,
I think we I mean a lot of people had seen her panels before.
I'd seen her panels just because I was looking at a couple people
them. Yeah. Um, she used to not get very many viewers, but she's
like kind of popped off and I think it's I think it's because
Andrew's been supporting her, but I'm not sure. >> Yes.
Yes. >> Okay. That that's I was just >> Was the Was
the Charlie Kirk justified, Connor? No. >> Do you think
that conservatives should fear for their life to be in public?
>> Do you think that you should actively work with and
support someone who thinks
>> Uh, not without criticism. No. >> So, as long
as you criticize someone saying that, then it's legitimate that
you work with them and get money and get clout from them. >> Uh,
I'm Okay. Yeah. >> Okay. So, if Sarah, for example, co-hosted
a show with a Neo Blank, you know, one of those people with,
you know, big fans of the Austrian painter. if she co-hosted
a show with him and made millions of dollars and promoted him
and went to college campuses with him and buddied with him and
introduced this gentleman to her mother and did all of those
things, right? But at the end of every show, she said, "By the
way, I disagree with you." You'd say that's perfectly reasonable.
You wouldn't question whether or not she was connected to that.
>> No, but I'm going to go ahead and give you a perfect
counter example, and you've already been talking for a minute,
so I would I would like it if you indulge me a little bit. Pured
thug is one of the most intelligent political philosophers that
I have met in recent memory. He is a fascist. >> Cultured
thug. >> He believes in political corp
>> Ultra thug apparently. Yeah. I don't know. I don't even
know who that is.
>> Is this story time from Connor? >> Uh it might
be story time from Connor. >> I'm flexible. Uh >> I
got this message from somebody. Okay, I'm not going to expose
who it is. I had this message. It's to do with the panel. Okay.
It's relevant to the panel. Hold >> Expose them. >> I'm
not going to expose them. I'm not. If you averaged these two
ninjas together, they would have a regular size earthworm gym
over here. It's crazy.
Uh, that's that's got to be a lens, right? That's got to be lens
warping, I think.
Uh, hold on. We're on Twitter Twitter >> No, Jube. I don't
like to fast forward through these talking. >> No, you
flexible authoritarianism and political corporatism. and he believes
in ethnogenesis.
Okay. If cultured thug contacted me because he is charismatic
and he is funny and he says, "Western North Carolina needs disaster
aid and I want you to come out pulse out water bottles. I'm going
to pay for it. I'm going to western North Carolina in order to
hand out water bottles and I don't give a that he's a fascist
because the shared goal is something that I care about." >> And
so is so your goal, correct me if I'm wrong, this is what you've
said. Your goal working with Destiny, I've seen you give two
arguments. It was like pulling teeth. But you've given them one
was because you need to work with them because it would take
you 10 years to accomplish what you want in your channel without
him. Correct.
>> Yeah. Yes. I work with influential people to gain influence.
Rob, you do the same. >> So you need to work with Destiny
who's saying that conservatives should fear for their lives in
public so that it helps your channel accelerate faster. That's
that argument. >> Okay. Rob,
you work with Andrew Wilson. >> He hasn't said that people
deserve to die. No, no, no, no, no, hold on. You are acting like
working with influential people is some kind of porative. It's
>> It's different. Working with >> it's that's obviously
not the primary attribute he's referring to, Connor. Dude, I
like Connor understands that his whole thing is he's anti-Trump.
This would be a defense to work with Trump on something, right?
But maybe Connor's saying that he would help Trump and he'd help
Trump accomplish all of his goals if he felt like he could do
more if he could grow himself and and maybe make up the harm
later on by growing himself. >> But no, okay, he's only
anti- something like in the moment cuz he said he's a never Trump
voter. That's why he's helping Democrats defeat Trump. But then
they put in Kamla and he's like, "Well, now I'm scared for my
guns, so now I'm not really defending Democrats." So he he just
actually doesn't stand for anything. And what he's basically
telling you is, listen, I lasted as a cop for three years. I
really don't know what else I'm gonna do besides YouTube.
Let me do this.
>> I mean, that's how it seems.
>> Yeah, it's uh is what it is, man. >> Influential
people can be something that Destiny is. He's certainly influential.
Ted Bundy was influential. Would you have worked with him? >> I
asked you this on Twitter. I asked you this on Twitter. I asked
you this on >> Do you think Steven believes in the Constitution
of the United States of America? I don't know if he believes
in it or not. I would suggest strongly. No. I think strongly.
I think strongly. I >> Have you thrown war in with a who
tried to overthrow the Republic of the United States of America?
>> I don't believe he is. You do. Do you believe Do you
believe that Destiny said that conservatives should fear for
their >> Yeah, I heard that. >> Do you believe that
Destiny is an
>> I think that Stevens,
>> dude, he's going to he's going to say yes. He just doesn't
want to say that yes. He doesn't want to give that yes directly.
He's got to like restate what Rob just said, but he's going to
restate it like one to one so he doesn't have to just say yes
to Rob there.
>> Spineless that he's done throughout this. That's why
I do not care to continuously call him a mall cop. Say that he
failed as a police officer or say that he lied about people dying
in his arm, whatever the [__] he did because he's
been an absolute garbage human being for the last year.
>> Don't care. I think that Steven's past or life is immoral.
>> Did you say that quote when talking about this that
no one is more negative than you?
>> So you would that would imply that you find what he's
done to be very egregious when it comes to his activities? >> Uh
no. So let's parse this. Let's
>> let's parse this. Hold on. Are we going to get a chart?
>> We need a chart. We got a chart. Connor, >> parse
this. Okay. >> You got to be careful though. I've heard,
okay, I heard from a young fellow that he actually typed in Conor's
chat. Conor, I missed all that. Could you redraw the chart? And
he got banned from that chat. Okay. So, you got to be
>> Any other people? Okay. But, uh, yeah, apparently he
typed that in Connor's Connor was like writing out one of his
charts and and he's like, "Okay, did you guys get that?" And
TW was like, "No, could you redo the whole thing?" And he got
perma. Well, wait, not perma timed out from the chat. I don't
know if he's permit or not. >> Yeah. So, you got to be
careful. Okay. Conor's a little sensitive about his >> Okay.
What Steven is accused of doing. And by the way, are we still
like Are we still Did they kick everybody else or >> She
put us up oneonone.
>> Okay, that's fine. Okay. >> It's a lovely speed
date for the two of you to get to know each other. >> All right.
It's fine. Okay. So, what Steven is accused of, which obviously
I morally condemn, is he is accused of the girl that he believed
to be 18 or
>> I just realized she kind of because we've been watching
the Conjuring kind of reminds you of the Annabelle doll.
>> Oh, yeah. >> I think that's what's offputting.
>> Yeah, I can see it.
>> Hello, can the jelly man, thank you for the gifted sub
to Verra. Verra getting his gift. >> Let's go. >> All
right, it's fine. very based. >> Okay. So, what Steven
is accused of, which obviously I morally condemn, is he is accused
of the girl that he believed to be 18 or 19, who lied about her
age, who creat >> Wait, wait, wait. Will he will he include
that Steven clearly kept after learning her age, even after confirming
her age? >> Homemade shared it with him and he shared homemade
with that other person. Now, on the scale of things, yes, this
is bad. condemn it. I hate promiscuity. I think sharing a homemade
>> I wish I wish Rob knew. I wish Rob could point it out.
>> You don't know what Rob knows. He's letting him. Yeah.
>> Yeah, he is listening. >> Gross. Whatever. Okay.
However, if you compared that to Andrew Tate, somebody who trafficked
women and forcibly them. I'm not going to pre pretend that Steven
and Andrew Tate are the same. >> Well, okay. No one would
pretend those same, but nonetheless, that doesn't force you.
That's not that doesn't force you to work with a person that
you don't think's as bad as Andrew Tate. I'll ask one more specific
question about Destiny's. The only reason I bring it up is because
you specifically said that you found it grotesque. If you would
have just said I don't believe it or it's not a big deal to me,
then I wouldn't even address it. I don't give a [__]
But you're the one who said you're the one who said that >> No,
no. You think that I can't work with people with whom I disagree
viferously about their personal lives. >> Well, it's I
think disgust implies an immoral action on their part. Like you've
implied there's a lot of immorality there. You work with people
who are consistently immoral and consistently hurt other people
and you enable them. You help them in some way. Like that is
obviously you are enabling that harm. It's not even a difficult
argument to make. Why does he always act like this is confusing
to him? Wait, you're saying if I like help the person who does
harm to others, I might be like responsible for some of that
harm.
Yes, Connor. Yes. That's what everybody thinks. That's what everyone
thinks, Connor. Yeah, because he doesn't just
he's he's not the person who is, hey, I'm like a really close
friend of this person and I'm always telling him like, tone it
down, calm it down. No, you're you're usually there saying how
useful this person is and you shouldn't act that way, but all
of these people who are criticizing you. >> You are like
a a shield for him and you're telling people, "Oh, but don't
worry, I'm also disgusted with it." Shut the [__]
up.
You're his bodyguard. You're his
He's got his own personal monk cop basically. >> Yeah.
He's like the I' I've referred to him as like for Destiny. He's
like uh Destiny's trying to get off a train. Okay. The cops are
like looking for him on a train and Destiny sorry Connor is the
hobo who gets up and starts off in the middle of the train. So
everybody looks and gets everybody's attention and Destiny makes
his getaway. Okay. Jeez.
>> Conor is the homeless man who on trains to draw people's
attention to himself. Okay. Okay. He's willing to humiliate himself
and he thinks like eventually if that guy gets away the world
will be a better place with just based on I guess nothing based
on his own hallucinations.
So
uh somebody said oh Philpal was saying Rob is literally becoming
a ghoulish creature. He has been saying unhinged after Kirk's
murder. What has he been saying that's unhinged after Kirk's
murder? Because unhinged to me would mean like somehow like calling
for violence or whatever. Rob does do or say you know quote unquote
unhinged but it's normally just running defense for Trump. Yeah.
He's not becoming Rob is exactly who he was before politically.
Yeah. Right. Um and some of his politics don't really match up
with who he is personally.
So I don't know what to do with that.
>> Yeah. I think that probably has to do with like who
he lives around and to be honest. Like I feel like he must have
a lot of friends that are in that same political cuz he's he's
a smart guy. He just he's got like a worldview that I don't know.
It's like resistant to
>> It just it makes me feel like something is off, right?
When you see the people who are the arguments that he makes with
Connor and Erday. Maybe that's just like a personal beef that
he has of being gaslit in this space by certain people around
Destiny. Um because he has been. And then you see him do the
thing where Pam Bondi, why do why do women not understand the
First Amendment? But then he has no [__] to say about
Trump not understanding the First Amendment. >> Like I
I hate politics like that. >> Yeah. I don't know. I >> But
I think Rob's maybe always been like I don't know. I don't know.
>> Yeah. I I really don't know. I
It might be one of those things. Let's see. He might have some
principles that are a little similar to Connor where it's like
yeah, Trump's bad, but like eventually the eventually like the
Democrats are worse and eventually it'll be better because I'm
protecting Trump. I have no idea. Uh, I feel like
I think if you had a conversation with him, he would say Trump
is just as stupid as Pam Bondi. I think he would have to I think
he would be intellectually honest. >> He might even say
Trump's less stupid. He understands he's just intentionally
>> He's being a moth boss, right? >> Yeah. Yeah,
he might say that.
>> One thing to disagree with personal life. It's another
thing to think someone's grotesqually immoral and work with them.
I'll ask this last question. Do you think I'll ask this last
question because I really find this part of it to be the least
interesting part. If it does turn out that he has videos of someone
who's under the age of 18 still saved on his computer, would
you continue working with him because he's >> No, but I'm
going to Oh, what age? Who created homemade shared it with him
and he condemn it? I hate gross women and >> pretend those
same. But nonetheless, that doesn't look as bad as Andrew T.
I'll ask one more specific question about Destiny, but the only
reason I bring it up is a big deal to me. Then I wouldn't even
address it. I don't give a [__] But you're the one
who said >> I didn't see how long the video was. I skipped
like >> You're the one who said that. You think that I
can't work with people with whom I disagree viferously about
their personal lives. >> Well, it's one thing to disagree
with personal life. It's another thing to think someone's grotesqually
immoral and work with them. I'll ask this last question. Do you
think I'll ask this last question because I really find this
part of it to be the least interesting part. If it does turn
out that he has videos of someone who's under the age of 18 still
saved on his computer, would you continue working with him because
he's influential? >> No, but I'm going to I'm going to
go ahead and >> Oh my goodness. But Condor is going to
do the same thing. Oh, Rob, you said if he has it saved on his
computer, it was on a external hard drive >> cuz the videos
aren't on his >> Yeah, it was actually on his phone. >> Those
videos aren't on my >> That's That's completely different.
That's completely different cuz his computer is where he works.
That's what I said. >> Yeah. It's going to be like he has
them on a hard drive that he doesn't have connected to computer
so he can't view them anymore. It's like, >> "Okay, bro.
Okay, bro." >> It's so bad when you know how they're going
to cope in the future when they're
>> Well, cuz I mean, if he's not coping in the future,
there's no way he can't be brain damaged enough to believe the
Destiny like spin on Destiny tripling down on having Child will
Mac, right? Like that is that is Destiny saying repeatedly over
and over and over again on like to Willy Mac in private. Yes,
I have saved that video, but I need it for my lawyers or I need
it for my case or maybe I need it for my case. I'm not sure I
can delete it. And it's like very clear what he means the whole
time.
>> So it's Yeah. It's just wild to me that um that Connor
would say this when it's like pretty clear that he did save those
videos even after he learned the age.
>> And then he kept coping on the age over and over again.
Yeah. That's uh JTO already covered the Tom Hman bribery scandal.
No, but I do have an article on it. So, I think I will look into
it in just a little bit. Okay.
Or link link one over it. I'll but I do want to go over it cuz
yeah, it's um we're we're doing a lot of Trump stuff today. Anyway,
but for now, Connor versus Rob Noir. We're continuing caveat
that. Okay. if he had solo making allegations in November 29th
of 2024
and he did not believe those allegations and he held on to it
as a part of his legal court case and then once
uh if if Rob knows any of this all you got to do here is say
oh well wasn't there a way for him to find this person didn't
he sell merch to this person didn't that person send him a picture
in that DG shirt like have been pretty easy to find this person
he knew her college
>> but it's also the idea like, "Oh, he believed she was
18." Why did he believe that? Is it because he made her go through
like a verification or is it because she just said, "No, I swear
Z's
>> I promise >> he did not do his due diligence."
>> It was alleged with confirmed information via Kiwi Farms.
He put that on a thumb drive and he says, "I believe that these
people were creating homemade that is illegal here. Law enforcement,
do what you want with it." I think that I don't give a [__]
>> The caveat the caveat on you working with him if he
has underage pornography. >> I don't want you to moral
grandstand because I want you to understand this. I want you
to understand I was trying to move on qualified difference between
holding on to evidence related to a case and turning it over
to law enforcement the second that you know it's illegal versus
holding on to it for your own >> Sure. There are reasons
it would be different. I think I think both reasons I understand
I understand they could be different. It doesn't matter. The
point I was trying to get is the fact that you said it doesn't
matter if you would listen to me. Listen, Conor, I know I know
a legal start. Are you starting?
>> I was going to say grand because you're morally grandstanding.
Because you're morally grand
homophobic slur next channel band two. Go ahead. Now, if you
would listen, what was the sentence I was going to finish with
when I was going to say it doesn't matter because alls I was
trying to get you to admit is there are things that Destiny could
do that you would say despite the fact he's influential, I don't
want to work with him. But you wouldn't let me get that last
part of the sentence out. Instead, you spured out over and over.
So now, now that you've admitted now that you've aditted, now
that you now, now that you've in a position, now that you've
understand
I don't give a [__] how you stop
This is what I know you learned from your daddy, Destiny. Like,
I understand this is what you do. You're just going to talk over
me because you're incapable of actually listening to the point
in a bit. I don't give a [__] I'm not going to stop
talking. I'm tired of this. You keep talking over me. You're
going to allow me to finish my point. You're going to allow me
to finish my point. I don't give a [__]
>> that's enough. >> I would like to make a point.
>> I would like to finish my point >> one at a time.
>> I don't care about your point. I would like to make
my point first.
>> Actual toddlers though. Like actual toddlers. I'm sorry.
It's like a lot of There just needs to be a way to point this
out. Like Rob was pointing it out, but then you keep going with
him and then I I don't think >> I don't know. There has
to be a way to like actually win in this [__] >> No,
Connor is kind of unhinged here, right? I think Rob is trying
to tell him I'm about to help you move past this, but Connor
wants to be able to have his gotcha moment. >> Well, I
Yeah, I just don't know. There should be a way to make other
people like humiliate other people for this. I just don't know
how that >> humiliate who like these two >> like
like when you're sitting there as Rob and Connor's just like
spurging over and over. There should be just the right combination
of words to totally humiliate him. Feel like a total He should
feel like a total >> You're supposed to not talk, right?
>> Yeah. Evil Johnny Bravo. Have I ever said that? I don't
recall ever saying that. I literally don't recall ever saying
that. I feel like you're entirely making that up.
>> So I don't recall ever saying that. It's kind of weird.
Say what? >> Uh he says I said that I hate debating people
who are difficult to talk to.
Wait, we've literally had Rob on here. >> Yeah, I don't
I don't know where that came from. >> Like multiple times.
>> I'm very confused by that to be honest with you. >> That
guy's talking to himself.
>> Uh, all right. Uh, listen, we're going to we're going
to go one at a time. >> I have I have like three more minutes
worth of then I'll leave >> one at a time. >> No,
I would like to make my point on your thing. >> Go ahead.
>> Okay. So >> ah baby >> you if you're being
good faith you'll recognize that effectively what I'm doing is
I'm consenting to an interrogation. You're speaking for twothirds
of the run time and then I'm answering your questions then you're
jumping to your next question. So I'm okay with that. I'm okay
with you like interrogating my values, virtues, questions, whatever.
But if I have a point to make or if I feel like you're asking
a question that implies something, I'm going to interrupt you
in order to point it out. And if you're not an you'll let me
do it. >> Okay. Thank you for adding that point that you
needed to get out that rub nothing for this whatsoever. Now that
you've admitted that there's things that can be done that now
that you've admitted that there's things that you could do that
someone could do. >> So sorry Connor needs to be told this
by people way more often. Connor, you make points that nobody's
contesting. You make points that are totally worthless to the
conversation and you waste everybody's time. It's the thing you
are famous for. It's the thing literally everybody knows you
for is coming up with stupid stories that don't drive home any
point and only serve to bloiate. Okay, to allow you to bloate
for minutes at a time and waste everyone else's life, okay? You
are a vampire. You are sucking the life out of everybody around
you. You are taking their time up for no reason at all. That's
what people for. That's who you >> He knows that. He just
expects people to let him. He expects nobody to be bothered by
it. I was in the Marines. I was a cop for 3 years. >> I
I sold insurance. Shut up, Connor. Nobody cares.
>> Jesus Christ. >> That would make them, even if
they were influential, you not want to work for them. I have
a couple more questions. Do you consider yourself a conservative?
>> And you'll acknowledge that Destiny said conservatives
should fear for their lives to go in public?
>> Yes. I will also add to the fact Hold on. Stop. I told
you that you're running an interrogation.
>> That is such a piss. Hold on. Nobody said anything.
Rob. Rob just starts laughing at him. He's like, "Hold on. Don't
interrupt me. Don't start laughing at me yet."
>> And you know what that reaction is? Like I just said
something. I should be embarrassed to say that. Hold on. I I
can I can explain.
>> I want to make your point. >> The meta is irrelevant.
Go. >> Okay. So, stop interrupting.
So the entire context of that sentence, which I disagree with,
which I've spent 5 hours criticizing, is the fact that he said
that conservatives should fear for their lives going to public
events and should fear being killed in order to pressure their
leadership to turn the temperature down. That's the full context
of the >> Yes, I understand the context of the quote. He
wants people like me and other
>> Let me finish. He wants people like me and people that
are conservatives, including you and people in your family that
presumably be conservative, to fear for their lives. And he has
a rationale because he thinks they should do that because he
doesn't like the way he vote. I find that to be despicable. The
fact that you're willing to work with a man, let me finish and
then you can finish your point. The fact that you're willing
to work with a man who said this, who said the following thing,
the worst thing that could have happened was the assassin's bullet
not hitting Trump, who said many times that he's tired of conservatives
and wants them killed. The fact that you're willing to work with
the man who said that and your argument is but I have to do it
for clout and for money shows the despicable character that you
have. >> Okay. So, I would like to make a point.
There are >> It's not going to address anything Rob just
said at all. >> As a matter of fact, I've made beautiful
drawings. I would love it if you >> Oh, bro. >> I
Are we serious? Are we serious?
Is he calling his weird charts drawings?
>> Where he goes over what age?
>> Demographic conceptual. >> Yes. His age of consent
drawings are his beautiful drawings. Okay. He's done a beautiful
drawing about the age of consent. And he needs Rob to take a
>> There are. As a matter of fact, I've made beautiful
drawings. I would love it if you reacted to my drawings, Rob.
I'm going to go ahead and pull one up. Okay. So, I would argue
that I was raised with probably five political philosophies,
okay? That that all are varants of >> Like I we just we
said exactly what he was going to do way before anybody actually
like it's so it's so it just happens every time. every
time he goes on to do this and just waste everybody's time. Like
I wish I wish there was anything we could we could just pretend.
We did cover that one to Yes. Um I wish we could like pretend
it was anything else, but he actually just does it every time.
It's perfectly predictable. Oh, you just pointed out that I'm
a piece of Well, have I told you at the time I sold insurance?
Have I told you about how how I was in the army? Have I told
you about when I was a cop? Have I told you about my investigation
when that person died in my arms? How? Yeah, I don't care. It
doesn't have anything to do with what we're talking about. >> What
about when he was patrolling the high schools? >> Trolling
the high schools. >> Political philosophies. Okay. That
that all are variants of conservatism
that support what the Republican party used to believe. Okay.
What I would argue is that it's Burkian conservatism, environmental
conservatism, neoonservatism, social conservatism.
>> Oh, you just pointed at a contradiction. Oh, well, I'm
going to state my worldview from scratch. Okay. What are you
going to do? This is gish galloping, right? Where you just load
a whole bunch of and the point is like somewhere in nowhere
anything that you've said, but now I'm overwhelmed with information
that you just threw at me. >> Well, it's I don't know.
I don't know what the term is. I don't know the logical fallacies
well enough to like say what it is. I'm saying that like >> yeah,
Gish Galloping implies that you're making a point. There is no
point. This is just >> he just he starts reconstructing
his worldview. He's like he like literally his brain blue screens
and he's like I'm going to redefine my entire worldview for you
so that hopefully you forget whatever we're talking about. >> No,
actually I think I understand what it is. I think every time
you have a debate with Connor and you try to press him on what
he believes, he realizes he doesn't know what he believes and
all of a sudden now this is a therapy session and I need to take
you back to my childhood. So it started when my father first
sat me down at the breakfast table told me about Marxist L whatever
it is he's like he's going through his childhood trying to unfold
the flower that is why the do I think these things it's a journey
for him too >> I guess so I that makes more sense I mean
sorry that doesn't make more sense that makes a lot of sense
for what he's trying to do realistically he's just kind of like
not thinking except about the Benjamins he's just thinking about
his channel right he's just thinking about the money he'll Are
you sure >> with Destiny? I think so. >> Are you
sure? Because if you look at how many figurines he has that he
paints, I think all of the money that he gets, he buys it like
he spends on little action figures to paint. I think his wife
is like, "Okay, here you could do this streaming thing. All of
the toys that you buy that the children don't get to play with,
all of those toys you coming out of your money." And then I think
he takes streaming as an opportunity for free therapy. >> Not
very good the therapy. Okay. He's not getting his money's worth.
He's not getting his money's worth. >> He's not getting
his money's worth. >> Maybe not. >> It's not working
out. Oh, what the >> in fiscal conservatism. All five of
these philosophies have been support. >> Wait, did I see
a tweet today that Sam Hyde came out and said he libs of Tik
Tok? Sorry, the the this is war tweet just came up and then I'm
like in my head I'm like, wait, I could have sworn I just read
today that Sam Hyde [__] libs of Tik Tok. I'm not
making that up, right? Hold on. Let me see if I can find it.
I'll hit by Nixon, Teddy. >> That's a way that's a way
better story than whatever the [__] Connor's talking
about. So, I'll just take my time while he yaps about nothing
and >> Roosevelt, Reagan, etc., etc. I can articulate with
perfect clarity how MAGA and Donald Trump have backstabbed every
single one of these philosophies. Not only can I say that they
have backstabbed and [__] on these five separate
philosophies, they are also contributing to deaths that maybe
not you, but other people absolutely
laugh about with reckless abandon. Donald Trump through the PEPAR
cuts is projected to kill 3 million people.
>> What was Rob's question? He asked about,
"Didn't Destiny say that he wanted conservatives to fear for
their life?" And did Connor just start talking about five iterations
of conservatism that he believes in?
yeah, he did, didn't he? >> Yeah. You I feel like I'm not
following, but I think I'm following perfectly.
>> All right. I'm trying to find
now. I'm trying to find the Sam High tweet. I got to find it.
Dude, did did he delete this? I'll take this screenshot from
Take this screenshot of my phone.
David really >> spam spam spamity spam spam. What are you
spamming? He's saying the Republicans have betrayed good oldfashioned
conservativism.
The destiny is justified. I guess that doesn't make sense. The
Trump is a populist,
not not a conservative
Republican, right? So, you'd say that
they haven't betrayed, they've just jumped ship.
Okay. Um, oh, you're still you're still listening to Connor like
you take it seriously. Porteller linked me the Del Gro tweet
and I literally didn't see it. So, I I myself went and found
the Del Gro tweet. >> Oh, that's why somebody said spam
spam >> Uh, Sam Hyde says he had with libs of Tik Tok eight
months ago. I libs of Tik Tok. I'm not lying. >> Including
that Libs of Tik Tok.
>> Nasty woman. Is she? I was trying to back you up. >> Is
she good? >> She seems fine. >> I don't know anything
about libs of Tik Tok. Listen, I the libs of Tik Tok. I
>> I libs of Tik Tok. This is real
>> No, not recently. This is actually real though. About
eight months ago, I libs of Tik Tok. >> I'm not lying either.
>> That's the crazy part.
>> Of course, we want to ask where >> in DC when
we were on tour for stand up. >> He's got a lot of people
watch him. I think just based on the clout. Yeah. >> No,
but I think because I watch him. Okay. I I actually I actually
can't judge. So, go on. Keep playing. >> She went to the
show, I'm guessing. >> Uh, no.
>> Does she tell you afterwards or before? >> I'm
being serious. She hit me up on
>> Pull up a picture of Liz Tik Tok and don't show me drinking
on camera.
>> There she is.
>> Make this flattering for Libs of Tik Tok. Oh, >> also
is Libs of Tik Tok white? Is this guy just giving up? I thought
this guy was starting the race war. Is he not
>> So, wouldn't he sleep with a white >> Yeah, that's
what I'm asking cuz I I I'm trying to figure it out. >> I
think we knew Libs of Tik Tok was white. Didn't Taylor Loren
already dox
>> Um, yeah, but I I couldn't tell from the picture. I
thought she was like, >> "Are you making a distinguish
a distinction between white and they all look the same?" >> No,
her name is like Rya Chaya Raichic.
>> Chai Ryick. She is white though. She's definitely white.
>> Or is it Chai? >> No. Cha. Chaya. >> But
she's definitely white. So >> that's some hippie ass parents
then. >> Oh, she's Orthodox. No way.
Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. Sam Sam doesn't believe in anything. Okay,
let's [__]
>> Anyway, we can continue on with this.
>> I don't know why I thought that was Why did I bring
that up? >> Cuz you saw it pop up on your phone. >> I
did see it pop up on my phone, but >> And you have ADHD.
>> I have ADHD. True. >> Through AIDS, he is projected
to kill 11 million people through chalera, through deni, through
malaria over the next 5 years in order to save 0.16% of the federal
budget. And then he slashed taxes, meaning that he didn't even
save any money. He just is projected to kill 14 million people.
Not only that, conservatives have laughed as they have deported
people without due process to a goolog in El Salvador. And then
they've laughed as innocent people have been tortured and and
so I'm not exactly in this whole perspective of, oh, let me clutch
my pearls because Rob's mad at me. Rob's mad at me because I
don't I'm not a Trump dick sucker. I don't give two. I think
that you your movement of >> weird that you're a destiny.
That's like the only that's the weird thing is like it Trump
could be really bad. It doesn't mean you're making good choices.
>> But have you have you considered that the thing that
you criticized me on? I'm just going to explain to you why there's
more important things or worse people in the world to focus on.
So actually my problems are really small compared to what you're
complaining about. >> Trump is bad. Okay. Trump is bad.
Like you're just the most useless person if every time somebody
tells you, "Hey, I kind of want to criticize that you do this."
And you're like, "Okay, well, do you know existed?" Like you're
just always going to point to something worse. It's [__]
useless. >> Um, listen, people are just realizing in in
their own ways, in micro in microscopic ways, okay? They just
need their own personal holocaust. And for a lot of people, that's
Donald Trump, okay? Have you considered that that happened? Donald
Trump happened, guys. Don't look at anything I'm doing, okay?
Dude, don't look at anything I'm doing.
>> Not looking. >> Hold on. I'm getting linked some
stuff >> Is this basically done or does Rob get back at
him? >> American Nacho. Every conservative who sweeps for
Trump, I think that you are stupid as you make the world a worse
place and I can't wait to beat you at the ballot box. >> Okay,
so two things. Well, three things real quick. Let me
let me let me respond. One, you were hired by Progressive Victory
and these other places to do a good job. How'd that work out?
You beat us at the ballot box, right? Oh, wait. Good spending
of that money. Progressive victory. You got your
[__]
>> guys. We had so many doors knocked on. How'd you do?
We got our asses kicked. But we had so many doors knocked on.
You don't even know.
>> Incapable of controlling it. I'll talk over you again.
I don't give a [__] You keep leaving me naked [__]
coin. It's ridiculous. Sarah, you know it's ridiculous. You know
it's [__] ridiculous. You know it's so stupid. If
you keep going, I'm going to play the gay. Uh, you know what?
>> I think you just You both deserve it. You both deserve
firemen. Firemen. Both of you. >> I want the firemen.
>> Rob, finish your point. >> Right. Like, so I let
him talk for like three minutes unfettered. I'd like to get my
points out, right? Like constantly he complains about interrupting
when it's only him doing it. Right. Second thing that I wanted
to say, all of that is a rambling nonsense. That is something
that's a false dichotomy. And the argument is you find Donald
Trump to be dis. >> Okay, this is [__] up on
cover. I appreciate this woman who I presume is a perpetual Vulcan
cosplayer.
>> What is a Vulcan?
>> Oh, it's the eyebrows. The people from Star Trek who
are they've got eyebrows very much like this. Hold on. >> Why
are you guys like this, >> bro? That was that was a crazy
comment. Holy [__] >> bro. We can't take you
guys anywhere. Here's Spock is a Vulcan. Okay. Got to look at
the the picture of Spock here with the eyebrows. >> Despicable.
Fine. Great. You're allowed to think he's despicable. You're
allowed to call yourself a conservative, not vote for him. Two
points. No problem. The difference is working with someone who
says all of this heinous [__] Notice what Connor
did was not answer for the fact that he says yes, he disagrees
with it. But Destiny did in fact say that he thinks conservatives
should fear for their lives based on who they vote. He didn't
answer. He didn't answer the fact that he knows Destiny said
the worst thing that could have happened was that bullet Trump
or missing Trump. He didn't answer for the fact that he said
several times heinous things about wanting conservatives to die.
It's not that he's voting for that guy begrudgingly. It's that
he's working with him admittedly for money and clout. Not only
is he working for him, it's not something he's doing begrudgingly.
He's introducing Destiny to his family. He wants you to believe
that it's like I have to it's me. I'm the big man. I have to
get this clout in money and I have to work with destiny who said
all these terrible [__] because only I Connor and
only via working through destiny can I stop the great orange
man. It's hubris. It's nonsense and it belies what's actually
happening which is Connor wants money and clout. That's what
this is about. And so he's willing to work with someone and then
make these false dichotoies. But Trump's a really bad man. The
last thing I'll say is this. I'll ask you this question, Connor.
If you seriously believe that because of Donald Trump, three
million people will die, would you be morally justified in taking
him out? >> Because
No. And the reason why is because we had a vote at the ballot
box. Okay. I think that while 3 million people dying from preventable
disease is horrific. And the fact that you just sidestep that
is repulsive to me. At the same time, I think that democracy
is the worst form of governance except for all the other ones.
And so what happened was you and your ilk because you're stupid
and you don't understand politics, you don't understand words,
etc., etc. You are through your vote 170 millionth guilty of
that sin. I'm not guilty of that sin. That's your cross to bear.
As a result, all I can do, hold on, I'm going to make another
few points. >> All I can do is I can advocate and fight
for within the realm of politics for people to see the world
that I do. And by the way, one of your points is so asinine,
it's unbelievable. You're saying, "Oh, you didn't win this election.
I guess you shouldn't participate in politics anymore." I'm sorry.
When Donald Trump lost in 2020, did you give up on politics?
>> No, I'll answer that question. I'll answer some points
because there's two bigs. I do want to read them. Uh Connor,
these are coming over, I believe, on your side. Uh the devil
says, "That's weird to say. Uh, dark money enjoying Connor holding
up the mirror. >> Hail Satan.
>> Uh, that is not on Connor<unk>'s side.
>> That in the name of Christ.
>> Get over. Pardon me. >> I want to make another
point when this is done. >> Of course you do. >> Loud.
Rob, I'm here to talk. >> Oh my god. This is your money.
I want to read it for you. Loud lizard says Rob got blown out
by Destiny over Obama and that is why he is obsessed. >> That's
not true. I would suggest there's one person that's probably
getting blown out by Destiny and it ain't memor.
>> So, so this is one of the things. This is why this belt
is not landing on me, okay? Is because we work within >> a
democratic republic. And guess what cloud is? Clout is popularity.
Do you know what money is? Money is energy. It's the ability
to take energy and spend it towards things that you believe in.
So you say that I want clout. You're saying that I want popularity
within a democracy. That's true. Do you know what you also say?
You want money. You're >> I This guy's been talking to
Aerodite way too much. He's like he's like moralized shilling.
He's like, "No, I have to I have to I have to excuse all of these
things because I can make more money and then eventually I can
help people." You like >> it's just They look so stupid
to everybody else.
They are the person. Who is it? Um, when I went to the DC thing,
I thought that it sounded nihilistic. I thought it sound defeative
or whatever. Seeing Emma Viglin sit on that panel and tell them,
"We do not matter. We are so insignificant in comparison to everything
that's going on." >> She didn't sit there and say, "I can
make a change. I need you to donate to me. Build my channel.
we will we are the revolution. No, she was like we are
>> Sort of like giving you a reality check if you will.
>> And then here is this person who was like a microscopic
version of her telling you I need this to influence the change
to take down Donald Trump and what they're doing to this country.
Like you look stupid. It's laring at its finest.
>> laring for money. >> But yeah, beyond that, sorry.
Like even beyond that for me, he's like actually trying to It's
not just that because it is that, but like beyond that, he goes
and just says like, "Yes, of course I'm trying to get more money.
Of course, I'm trying to do that so I can do the things so I
can solve the problems I want to >> As he paints figurines.
>> Well, he >> he is so uninformed.
He doesn't actually spend time researching anything. He uses
recycled points that he learned from debates like a year ago.
And this is so important to him that he's willing to, you know,
work with some bad ombres. >> Oh, bad ombres. >> It's
a joke. He is a joke. >> Uh, yes. Hey, hey, hey. He's just
>> I I Does he even Does he actually debate politics anymore?
Feel like he debates his relationship with Destiny and drama.
>> That's where he's put. >> Does he do politics
content? >> Does he do like this is my opinion on politics?
cuz I feel like I do I feel like we do more of that than he does
and we're like a drama channel. >> Well, cuz you don't
understand he's in the process of like normalizing and defending
somebody who has the clout and money for him to be able to do
the political debates that he was able to do before. So, right
now he's tanking his own so he can fight in the trenches.
>> I guess like I guess so. I >> I don't know. Do
you Who do you Who else do you see dodging debates right now?
dodging politics.
nobody. I feel like politics is like all polit like I feel like
everybody who wants to do politics is talking about political
[__] right now. >> Did he do like maybe he
did streams in Charlie Kirk? I don't know. >> Well, I'm
sure he's streaming on his channel.
I think. Didn't um didn't Pisco say that him and Connor are doing
a weekly show? >> They said they were going to. Yeah, >> I
think they have been doing it. >> I saw I saw him on there
talking about >> I don't think I could sit through that.
I just can't do the the story time when he like is kind of caught
out on not really having any principles and that it's just like
I need to reconstruct my entire worldview to waste time or I'm
going to tell you a totally irrelevant story. It's like one of
those two responses every single time.
Like I won't I won't actually categorically respond to you or
I won't actually tangibly respond to you. I'm just going to reconstruct
my entire worldview for you. So you have to like >> it's
not going to help you. You can just restate the same criticism.
It's not an answer to your question, but I'm going to reconstruct
my entire worldview for you or I'm going to tell you a story
that's irrelevant. >> Yeah. Cuz I think for the most part,
I don't really want to watch a political streamer who I don't
want to who I don't think is more informed than me or I don't
think is just like funny and adding something to it or like I
wouldn't want to sit down and have a beer with them. There's
like something I look for in a political content creator that
I can't just get myself out of literally just reading articles.
So, if there's no entertainment factor or if you don't have like
such a charismatic personality that I'm drawn to watch your channel,
I'm not watching it. >> Yeah. Well, what about Hold on.
What if they're really funny in terms of >> like I think
Kyle Kolinsky I don't like a lot of his politics.
He can sometimes be funny watching him. It looks half of his
YouTube videos look like he just got kicked out of the house
cuz he's talking too loud. And so he's like streaming from his
car like outside the golf course like all right this just happened
today you guys and I'm like why is this [__] in his
car?
It's like it's a little charming. You catch a boss video here
and there if it's not too >> You're calling me a when I'm
clearly smarter than Connor yet you sit fat obese on your couch.
>> Thank you very much for the so not erodite for the three
bucks. Okay. Thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you. Quick
donation. Sorry I just had to >> No. Fine. Go ahead. >> Kyle
Kolinsky does create banger content from his car when he's been
kicked out of the golf. I I feel like it's not the house. I feel
like it's the golf course.
>> He's he cuz he he is always wearing like a polo, like
a golf polo or something. When he's out there in his car and
he's got like the sunglasses, he's ready to >> It's like
it's people who you want their opinion on something that you've
already informed yourself of. Like I know what's going on. Okay.
What does that [__] Steven A Smith have to say? Cuz
why the [__] did you post a video about what's going
on,
you know? You just know it's going to give you something that
you wouldn't have gotten elsewhere on your own. >> Yeah.
Yeah. A different perspective.
>> Not not the every Well, maybe with Stephen A. Smith
with Kyle Klinsky. Probably not the everyman perspective. Kyle
Kwinsky.
I would expect it to be um not quite that, but um
All right. Where are we with this? Oh, Connor re is Connor reconstructing.
No, no, no. He did that already. They >> I want money because
I want energy in order to spend it. >> Oh, he's he's uh
moralizing being a like grifter. He's saying it's moral to grift
right now.
That's that. Sorry. That is like basically the core of the argument
is it's moral to grift. It's moral to grift because eventually
you'll have more, you'll have more money, you'll have more clout,
and you will eventually be able to do the things you want to
do. So, it is a actually moral to grift. White hat grifter. Yes.
Like white hat grifting. I am griing with the intention to not
grift later on. >> That's great. You can never say it's
a grassroots movement. You can never say that we have small donations
getting us to build this coalition. You are you are a grifted
coalition. >> These might
>> I think that's something I stole from Hassan. Not the
Midas that's you. Hassan basically saying like you don't get
to call yourself a grassroots movement when you have corporate
money funneled through like you know secret ways coming into
you. >> Well and I mean he does openly have
corporate money.
>> Like he is he is on a channel that is just paid for
by Midas Touch. But I think I think he is transparent about that.
Like I think he says it's the Midas Touch network that fun. >> But
he's also being transparent about I think it's a moral good to
Grift. >> Oh good. like, oh, if I'm just like really honest
about what I'm doing, then then it'll be fine. No, sometimes
people who are honestly grifting are just still looked at as
grifters. >> I think also the thing he doesn't realize
is is you move move with that that logic will take you down a
path that ends up like not being good. Like I'm sure that >> it
portrays some previous arguments that you've had. Lauren Southern.
No, I'm sure Tim Temple or Lauren Southern probably had like
intentions to get back to something more like what they believed
in or didn't even realize. But like you'll you'll start grifting
in a direction. You'll start getting carried by people in a direction
you don't want to go. It takes a very I don't know if there is
a person who could like do that kind of grifting, do that kind
of like uh like selling
selling their credibility for money and then they can get back
to like I I just feels like it only goes bad. It doesn't get
better.
And I think honestly if you can't see what is troubling about
it,
go down the path of grifting. I just kind of don't ever need
to hear from you again because I think that you've just shut
your brain off or it just was never turned on to begin with.
>> Yeah. Hopefully hopefully Connor just gets back to making
Warhammer content. That's his best content, isn't it? He needs
those he needs those Warhammer viewers back. Get them out get
them out of politics. I'm sorry. It's just not
It's not the thing, man. is simply not >> I thought you
said you can never really go back after you dip into politics.
>> Uh I was saying you can't really go back to not grifting.
Uh why is your mic so ADHD runs me? Is that me or is that um
is that Cherry? >> Yeah. Which one's quieter? Cuz maybe
I'm not talking into mine. >> Uh we have like directional
mics here cuz we're in the same room. So if I'm not talking directly
into it and if I'm looking around I'll you'll see me get like
quite a bit quieter if I like get over here or get over here.
Right. So, if I talk directly into it, I can be quite loud. But
>> Oh, it's good if I'm a little quieter. Sometimes I have
to yell. You know why?
>> All right. Yeah. Yeah. I think it's I think it's just
if I look away, I'll get more used to it. Okay. I'll get more
used to talking directly into the mic as we go >> on things
that I care about. Not only do I want to uh take care of my friends
and family, which I don't think you begrudged me for, but I would
also love to do things. I'm in a little political group called
the real Republicans and we're coming up with crazy ideas on
what to do with this money in order to make the world a better
place. So the fact that you think that I'm just >> No,
that is actually I remember my mind being a little bit blown
and just I never voice this because I don't know if I'm being
insane, but over the chorus stuff, the stuff that happened with
Chorus, do you remember that
very large woman that people thought that she was running the
Democrats trying to outreach to
disaffected young men? >> Oh, fat white woman. >> I
can't remember her name. I know who you're talking about. I thought
you Juliana. Yes, thank you. >> I thought you were talking
about Brianna Woo, like a 6'7.
>> No, no, no. The fat one. >> Um, if you remember
that one, she went on talking about how I'm not going to regret
taking this money because she has like children and saying how
in like 4 years she will have had her college loans paid off.
And I'm like, what?
>> They're worried about like generational wealth. I'm
like, "Wait, so you're
>> I feel like you're not supposed to say that part. >> I'm
not over >> I'm not over here wishing you like student
loan debt, but usually people get into politics to try to do
something to make like debt affordable
or like students student loan debt paid." Yeah. But she's talking
about that money is going to help make sure that she doesn't
have her It just sounded so weird. >> Listen, guys, you
don't understand. There there's like a saying that they say in
socialist circles. It's like
you can save time with money and money is time. And actually
>> now we have a lot of time.
>> Like I Yeah. Now I have more time to make more content
because I have a lot of money and like you don't understand how
I can use that in the future to like actually make a really big
difference. Oh, you know who else did this today actually now
that I remember it >> is uh >> is Destiny. Destiny
talked about how guys I'm like losing. I'm listen I'm not going
to make my YouTube income. I'm like I'm in my lawsuit. So this
takes away from the things I'd like to do like pay for political
organizing and put money behind political movements. So I guess
I just won't get to do that anymore. And it's like okay like
I okay >> I thought he didn't I don't know. >> It's
it's just mind-blowing that they're like yeah if I had money
I could be a better person. It's like have you tried being just
a better person in general to like just in general like generally
just trying to be better >> a million dollars this year?
>> Yeah. I don't know. >> Um, but yeah, it's it's
like somebody coming out there and saying there is like a housing
crisis and most kids my age aren't going to be able to afford
a house, but thankfully I care about these issues and I'm representing
you for these issues and because I'm working with Chorus, I'm
going to be able to buy my first house in two years. Like what?
It sounds like we're on the same page, but somehow you're getting
a house and
>> what what's happening for me? >> But yeah, >> hold
on. You you helped it happen. Okay. Your small your small dollar
donations to me also helped that happen. Yes. >> Helping
young people afford houses. But that's that's what Counterpoints
just said right now. I like taking care of the people around
me. >> Okay, cool. That's why everybody wants to make money.
Like what the are you >> It's uh it's just getting and
they the weird thing is they come on these things. They're like
this is a perfectly moral argument. It's a great argument right
now. It's like, no. As opposed to the people who don't want to
take care of the people around them who don't want to be financially
secure, right? >> You don't want me to make money. So,
you want me to be homeless. >> You want my kids to be homeless.
>> You want my kids to be homeless because that's what
is going to happen if I have to get up and go get a real [__]
job. >> Snorting these drugs or I'm running a second family
or banging hookers. You're a idiot. You don't know what you're
talking about. You're criticizing something that everybody within
politics does. And by the way, do you know what politics is without
money? Do you know what politics is without influence?
It's having an opinion. I'm not interested in having an opinion.
I'm interested in
>> Okay, I'll answer this. I wonder if that group you're
in with those Republicans, your super cool Republican group,
if they too fear for their lives like Destiny wants when they
go out, right? Won't that be great there? Or you can't control
yourself. You absolutely can't control yourself. It's pathetic.
He literally just let Connor soy rants in a totally direction
and he makes like one pill and Connor just or sorry one pill
one point or the the shade master so ogre pill comment from Ken
the jelly man okay one point and Connor immediately cuts him
off >> everybody's quiet >> right like it's absolutely
pathetic >> I'm not a directly addressing I cannot debate
you at any time you're the person that had to rage quit last
time after spuring out homophobic slurs you're the person that's
so much of a Come on, Rob. While you're taking while you're taking
the high road, did you say something about my wife? >> You
say something about my wife.
>> Uh,
let's go. Let's go, Rob. >> Man of honor. >> Yes.
Do you want me to answer? >> Yeah. So, don't take the high
road with me, Rob. Nobody >> believes now. I know it's
difficult. >> I prefer to keep the personal stuff off the
screen if we can. I don't want to hear anything about >> you.
Bring my wife or you bring my family into it. You bring my honor
into it. I'm going to call you the f slur. If you were in person
and you said that to my face, it would get person. >> I'm
going to answer this. Your wife publicly called me gay several
times. >> I addressed what the
>> Wait, what? >> She did. Uh,
Mrs.
Counterpoints. I have no issue with her. She said said a couple
nasty things about me in the past, but I don't. It's whatever.
But she does like to talk on Twitter. Mhm. >> You know,
I can't really judge. I'm a talker on Twitter, but Connor can't
be like Connor can't react like this if his wife likes to engage
in arguing and chitalking people on Twitter. If she's going to
call Rob gay, he probably gets to make a comment. >> Yeah,
I would imagine. Oh, apparently the f slur.
>> Weird cuz Rob seemed like the type to be super straight.
You know what I mean? >> Yeah, I think so. >> Listen,
I'll leave the pan I'll just leave the pan I'll leave the pan.
This is what it's going to be. I'll leave the pan open.
I think his wife deleted her Twitter.
>> After the maybe after the weird
>> she certainly didn't like that he was doing the drawings
in the first place if if memory serves. Okay. He got kind of
bitched out for doing drawings.
>> I'm pretty sure. >> I'll leave the panel. This
is what it's going to be. I'll leave the panel. This is what
it's going to be. I can't
All right. We'll see. >> These these people are all like
subhuman. if they can't understand. Like Connor's like, "You
make comments about my wife." And Rob's like, "I'll address this
real quick." They're like, "No, no, no. Don't don't. You can't
do that." It's like, >> it's like, "Hold on. The way that
you guys just worded this automatically makes me look like I
need to go up on a cross." Like, >> so he needs to call
American Nacho a and then say, "No, no, no. Don't address it.
Don't address it. Don't address it. No, just let it hang. Just
let it hang >> We'll We'll see you guys if that's how it's
going to be." But I think it's fair game. Constantly Connor interrupts
as I'm trying to talk constantly >> And I'm trying to shut
it down, but nobody will shut up so that I can shut you up. >> So,
I'm making a point. I didn't go after Connor's family just willy-nilly.
I went after a person who I wasn't treating as an inferior because
she came after me first. I didn't know Connor's wife. She >> I
don't care. >> Shut up. No one ask you. Shut up.
>> I don't care. >> That's a woman. That's a woman.
You have to let that woman call you the f slur, >> Ah,
someone give me that guy's Twitter. I'm going to call him slurs.
>> That's what you got to do. >> You got to take
it. >> You just got to take
a
[__] Conor's nuts and sh
>> That's your gay firefighter, I guess. Cool, cool, cool,
cool. What happened to Rob? Rob, hello. What?
>> I'll finish my point. So, um, if someone I think that
>> just stop. Listen,
tone it down a little. Drop the temperature. Everybody take a
deep breath. But >> Bob's totally calm. He just doesn't
want that to be laid out. He's laying out his point. He's not
saying, "Oh, this person's a total." He's saying, "I just talk
back to her because she talks [__] to me." That's
what that's all he wants to say, but he wants to finish his >> Bubble
in your mouth if you need to.
All right, Rob.
If someone, regardless of their gender, decides to call you names
or enter into the debate, it is appropriate to respond in kind.
That's it. She kept talking about my genitals and what I was
doing with other people's genitals, and I merely made the point
that she seemed oddly interested in me and genitals. If that
upsets Connor, then clearly he should tell his wife that she
shouldn't be making those sorts of comments. He made the homophobic
slurs. No. >> Come on, Connor. Can't you control your wife's
Twitter like you control her bank
>> It would get the channel banned and didn't care. Now,
the point I'm trying to make is that he ra he he rage quit after
that and as he shows his cowardice here by needing to constantly
interject. So, I make the point that he's working with a person.
Everything that he's saying here is a nonsequator. He's making
the seeming >> I just want to point out that me being a
kinder person than Hutch. I recognize Rinyald. Okay. I recognize
Renyald as that guy who was in the debate with Hutch and he was
on Hutch's side and then it was like Dickers and Fabian and one
other guy. Can't remember off the top of my head
>> this Renald guy. This Renyal guy, but Hutch didn't remember
him. Hutch was literally going to leave. He was like spurting
out and like leaving the debate. He's like, "Thanks to whatever
your name is." And this Reinald guy's like, "It's Renald actually."
>> Bottom left. I just wanted to point out that I better
at remembering faces than Hutch. Okay. >> Excuse that.
Okay, that's the bar. I'm better than Hutch.
>> Okay. It's pretty [__] low. >> Yeah,
it is. Hutch is pretty [__] low. Thank you for making
that point as
>> One that engages in a corrupt way in politics does.
I had to embezzle the money because money is power and connections
and there >> Yeah,
Rob's just going to make the point that we were making. Yes,
obviously. I had to do this. I had to listen. My career was on
the line. My career was on the line and I'm going to do big things.
I'm going to save people. >> Therefore, I had to do it
so that I >> Have you considered if you can't if you can't
save people without without obiscating for a pest or defending
somebody who saves while knowing the person is under 18. You
can't do those things. Then maybe you have been filtered by the
universe. Maybe this isn't your chosen career path. Maybe you
should off. >> No, dude. It feels like every career path
maybe has been with the idea that I'm going to be a hero. I'm
going to save someone in a war. I'm going to save someone in
the line of duty. I'm going to save someone now in politics.
>> Oh my god. Yes. Yes.
That's Counterpoint's entire life. He is the dude. That's his
hobbies. Warhammer. He's the hero. He's the fascist emperor is
going to take over the universe. He is going to save the human
race. That's Connor<unk>'s entire life. Blade bear.
>> Oh [__]
>> He's the main character for real. For >> Political
goals. I remind you there's an answer that Connor could have
done. He could have chosen to work with someone who's not calling
for people that are Republicans to fear for their lives when
they're out in public. He could have worked with someone who
wasn't saying the worst thing that could have happened was the
assassin's bullet, Miss Donald Trump, or many other things that
he said like that. He chose not to because through his own hubris,
he's trying to make excuses that he needs to be the one that
steps up and gets this clout so he could stop Donald Trump. Of
course, I'm not saying >> I think
>> I think that's a woman. >> No, I'm talking about
Connor with his
>> Oh, he's uh >> he's like, "Hello, I want to speak."
>> Yeah, he's trying to interrupt, but he's trying to control
himself. That's the best he can do for self-control right >> You
lose in politics that you don't compete anymore. What I'm saying
is when you sell your soul to work for people this disgusting
and then you still don't win, it should cause some self-reflection.
the idea of eliminating PEP FAR. This is constantly the justification
that counterpoints and people like Destiny make. It's okay for
us to do these heinous threats. It's okay for us to do really
bad [__] because our opposition's super evil. He
says that he's the real conservative and Trump's not. Let me
ask you this. Based on the same logic, Connor one, two-part question.
one, will you admit that there are many Democrats or people that
call themselves Democrats or liberal or left-leaning that say
that the traditional Democratic party in the form of Joe Biden
or Camala Harris don't represent them? And second, given that,
do you think that they would be justified in saying, "Well, we're
allowed to work for people calling for the deaths of Democrats
because we need to get the Democratic party back to its rightful
place."
>> Okay, before anybody respond, the second >> we
have so that we have a moment to take a deep breath. Let me read
some super chats and then I'll kick. >> Honestly, if Connor
had a little more energy, he would start talking about Burk and
conservatism again. You see, Rob, I believe in a little ideology,
a little little uh offshoot of conservatism called Burkian conservatism.
It was come up with by a man named Edmund Burke in the year 19
whatever. I >> start reading off the Wikipedia. >> Yeah,
you just start reading a Wikipedia
>> But this I'm sorry, she just decided that was a very
wordy question and she's like, "Well, now we're going to take
some super chats.
No one's going to remember what the Rob just said. >> No.
Uh, I'm guessing not. Do they Do they keep going? That's got
to be pretty close to the end here, right? >> That's so
Rob talks like he's always ordering at a drive-thru.
Why does this feel so real? And you never know if they got your
whole order. You know what I mean? And it's like, read it back
to me. Or I guess now they have like the screens.
>> They do. They do. Drive-throughs are a lot better nowadays.
Okay. What am I doing here?
I've noticed that we seem to have hit another hour on the stream.
I am not. >> Why? Why did we hit another hour? >> I
don't know. But we're not going to do it. We're going to add
more time tomorrow. Okay. We're adding time on to tomorrow if
you guys donate today. Okay. >> Oh, hallelujah. >> That's
how we need to do it cuz uh I'll I'll keep the time up so I know
how much to add over to tomorrow. But um yeah, we it was just
a long day today. Okay. Okay, we had to spend I spent all this
time we spent all this time getting the audio stuff working and
this is just better. We we tried to do it with the Discord before
and it would reverb and the reverb was bad. So
anyway, we got it all set up today. What is this? What portabeller
just link? Just going to get this sorted again. >> This
is the same guy on two very different camera lenses. Okay, this
is just showing the the power of a camera lens. Okay, the wide
lens, the fish the fisheye lens. Okay, amazing stuff. Get right
back to you counter points. Another new account says, "Jesus
Jesus Christ, counter, can you stop breaking to or did the Marines
not teach you discipline?" Marathon Kev says, "Sister Sarah,
shout out to you, Marathon Kev."
>> change to the other avatar for the last hour. No, but
I also don't know if I'm going to do an hour, but I can change
the avatar. Hold on. >> What do you mean you don't know?
I thought we already said we're not doing >> Well, sorry.
Not doing an extra hour. We still have an hour and a half left
even >> We're going to do the hour and a half
>> We'll do the 30 minutes at least. >> Oh, I thought
we were going to I thought we were ending so much sooner. I was
already thinking in my head, oh, I'm going to go sit in bed and
watch movies. >> Uh, you can go sit in bed and watch movies
if you want. I can finish. >> What? No, I'm not lazy. I'm
working a job right now. >> Yeah. Okay.
This is this is real work. This is real work. >> This [__]
Guys, if you want to help save democracy, I implore you to sub
and donate right now. Okay? You can you can help do your part
to save democracy, to take the fight to Trump, to save your country
from a fall into fascism, a descent into fascism. Okay? And giving
me money is the only way to prevent that. Now, will I do tangible
work? Will I do things that you could actually track and make
sure that like this is actually making progress towards your
country being better? No, I will not. But I will show up every
night and I will watch a couple of YouTube videos. Okay, I'll
do that at minimum. I >> And I will sometimes uh a log
people who lie to you and say that they are making political
change. Okay, so you don't have to.
>> Boom. That's It sounds like we're doing a lot. I think
we're getting a lot done. Okay. Sorry. There's one more. Top
Bronson. Top Bronson's enjoying his memes. Okay. I don't know
why they're all at my expense,
>> but there we go. We Someone asked if we could do a different
avatar for the last hour of the stream or something. >> This
one. I'm scared. Where is it? I >> It's on the stream.
Oh, I didn't send it to you. I just put it on the stream. >> Yeah,
I'm waiting for it to come up. >> If it's not there yet,
it should be >> Oh, there it is.
>> Uh, it's good stuff. Okay, what do we got? We got one
last thing. >> Why you got a nose like that? >> I
think it's supposed to be like a muppet.
Like a muppet or I don't know, some other kind of I don't know.
>> I like this.
>> What are you? It's like a hand pupp. It's like a mannequin.
It's like a >> Like a dummy. >> I got my hand. >> Ventriloquous
dummy. Yeah. Ventriloquist >> I'm making his mouth move.
>> You can actually do that. Yeah. Okay. >> Is the
Amber Rose a panda. Don't ever go >> You're supposed to
close your mouth when you get the sock puppet to speak. No. >> No.
We're not saying I'm good at it. >> Okay. We've got the
Tom Hman thing. I did want to look at I don't know where I saved
the links to that.
>> Who's Tom? >> Wait, what? Also, can you change
the background music? It's
off my ears. >> Don't skip what I sent. It's the cap. Okay.
All right. Listen, Connor had these arguments. Connor did his
thing where he just restates his worldview again and again and
again. Ral wants me to look at this. I don't know where this
is from. >> Also, I just want to say that >> I will
just be everything I said today.
Ruben donated $3. Top Bronson said, "I inspired that because
of my joke earlier." Top Bronson is the best. >> We love
Top Bronson. This househ.
>> Sorry. Continue. Continue.
>> I've just thought about all of the very judgmental,
very um anger on my heart messages I've said today on stream.
And you know what? Not good. >> Not great. >> My
bad. >> Uh all right. We apparently this is Connor. Conor
must have hopped onto Desi stream or something, I guess. >> Oh.
Um, I I had one of the best political commentary weeks I've ever
had in my entire life. I also had a decent Warhammer girlfriend.
Damn. >> And uh yeah, that that's another thing, too. All
right. Yeah, if you if you retire or whatever, then I mean, I
can get you into Warhammer. You know, we can spend up that retirement
money on plastic crack. That's one way to spend your time.
>> So Connor says, including this panel with Rob, this
is the best week of political commentary he's ever done. Pretty
special, >> dude. I it is this is like a grown man that's
like okay if you retire we can play this game together.